[Music]
welcome back time travelers we have all
traveled through time and space to be
here and i am really really excited
today this is absolutely one of my
favorite lectures to give in class to my
my graduate students and i think this is
going to be one of the absolute most
useful lectures for you so today we're
going to talk about one of the most
fundamental methods in solving partial
differential equations which is
separation of variables it's a way of
turning a partial differential equation
like laplace's equation
into a system of ordinary differential
equations
that we know how to solve and then we
can reconstruct this kind of spatial
solution of this this partial
differential equation from those those
ode solutions so this is a cornerstone
of modern applied mathematics in
engineering in science in computation
and so i'm going to walk you through the
separation of variables and i'm going to
introduce it specifically to solve
laplace's equation in two dimensions
for the steady state heat distribution
on this
rectangular metal plate
so we're going to
solve laplace's equation in 2d to find
the steady state heat distribution and
we're going to do it using separation of
variables okay this is a big one we're
going to cover some of the most
important concepts in
in engineering math
for example we're going to show that
when we take our separation of variables
and we get our system of ordinary
differential equations
we will
essentially derive that the fourier
transform sines and cosines the basis of
sines and cosines are the eigen
functions of laplace's equation on this
domain so really important connections
and i'm super excited to walk you
through this
believe it or not this is actually the
first weekend i'm back in seattle since
our year-long
sabbatical at caltech
and i couldn't wait i've been planning a
whole set of videos for a while so i
decided to come in
and film this up
all right and when ever you solve a
partial differential equation of course
you need
some combination of initial conditions
and boundary conditions depending on if
it's a pde in space or in time for this
laplace's equation and remember
laplace's equation del squared u
is just the second partial derivative of
u with respect to x
squared plus the second partial
derivative of u with respect
to y squared
equals 0. so this is a partial
differential equation because
u
is a function of x and y
and we are representing
conservation of thermal energy or you
know the steady state heat distribution
in terms of these partial derivatives
with respect to x and with respect to y
uh and we derived the heat equation in
the last lecture in two dimensions as a
again a conservation of thermal energy
in a volume or on a square on a
rectangle
and if you take the limit as time goes
to infinity so that's what i mean by
steady state all the transients die out
then you arrive at this steady-state
heat distribution equation given by
laplace's equation
now we need some uh
boundary conditions to make this a
well-posed problem that we can solve
and so the first boundary condition
on the left wall so what we're going to
assume is that we impose a constant
temperature distribution on the left
wall the top wall the right wall and the
bottom wall
and so
u
at x equals zero that's the left wall
for all points y
we're going to say that that equals
f 1 of y some some specified function f
1
which is a function of the y variable
which goes from 0 to some height h
similarly we're going to specify at the
top boundary condition u
now this varies in x u of x comma h
equals f
2 and this is a function of x because it
varies in the x direction
we're going to specify a right boundary
condition
u
at
x equals l
for all of these points y equals f 3.
again this is a function that varies in
y
and finally we specify our fourth
boundary condition at the bottom
which is u of
x again
fixed at y equals zero
that's what the bottom line equals f 4
and this is a function of x
so okay now we have a partial
differential equation
and enough boundary conditions that this
is a well posed problem i'm going to
walk you through solving this using the
separation of variables
and this is actually kind of a gnarly
problem to solve with all of these
boundary conditions
and so one of the things i really like
to do in my class i think this is
illustrative of how you take a
complicated problem like this and break
it down into a simpler problem
because laplace's equation is linear
meaning
if i had a solution u1 and a solution u2
and a solution u3 if i add all of those
solutions up that is still a solution of
laplace's equation it's a linear partial
differential equation
and so what that means
is that if i have
this full set of boundary conditions
where i have you know f1
f2
f3
f4
and i have my solution u of x comma y
okay that's my full solution
this is equal to the sum
four simplified problems where in the
first problem i have f1 zero zero zero
okay so i've i've kept my f1 boundary
condition but i made all of my other
ones zero we're going to call this u 1
of x and y
plus
another set
0 f 2 0 0
plus
0 0 f 3 0
plus
0 0 0 f 4. and again the solution of
each of these
sets of boundary conditions is u1
u2
u3
and u4 and because this is a partial
differential equation that is linear if
i add up these four solutions u1 u2 u3
and u4
it is a solution again of laplace's
equation that satisfies the boundary
conditions f1 f2 f3 and f4 at those four
sides
so it's i'll show you in this this video
so this is going to um
my guess is this is going to be like 30
or 40 minutes so so buckle up
i'm going to pick this one here because
this is the easiest one for me to solve
with the boundary conditions
and then as kind of a homework problem
you can solve these other ones and add
them up to get the full solution so i'm
going to pick this problem here and i
think i should just probably write this
out as
uh this is where we're gonna remember
what problem we're solving so we're
solving del squared u equals zero
with the boundary conditions zero zero
f
3
0 let's call this f 3 of y
and i'm just going to write down
my boundary conditions to be very very
explicit so i have u of
x comma 0.
so u of
x at the y equals 0 is 0.
i have u of
x at the top of my square at h
also equals zero
i have u of x equals zero all along y
equals zero and i have u of
x equals l at the far length of my
domain
for all points y equals this f3
of y so these are my boundary conditions
this is the problem we're going to solve
and we're going to solve it using
separation of variables
okay good i'm gonna erase this because i
need all the board space i have uh if
this takes too long to erase i might
speed it up
all right uh time travel good
so now we're to solve this simplified
problem
of laplace's equation using separation
of variables
and this is an incredibly powerful
technique
which essentially
was introduced by uh jacob bernoulli in
1690.
and 1690 was a very very interesting
time in europe uh mathematically
so if you think about it in that century
from
1600 to 1700
kepler had used tico bray's data to
solidify the copernican model with the
sun at the center of the solar system
galileo had been imprisoned or under
house arrest and died in his home
in the middle of that century
and two or three years before jacob
bernoulli introduced the separation of
variables to solve this isochrone
problem newton released his principia so
just an incredibly
rich time in
in the history of math and physics and i
actually think that the separation of
variables is one of the culminations of
this kind of
rich thought environment
so the idea
is that we are going to take our
solution so we're going to say u of
x comma y
this is a huge assumption we're going to
say that this equals
some function of x some function in the
x direction
times
some function
in the y direction
now this is a really big assumption
we're assuming that these dynamics in x
and y
can be split into the product of
functions of x times functions of y
now that means that there are no weird
cross terms here
like
well this means that i can factor my
solution into a term a set of terms in x
and a set of terms in y
but that it is separable into into those
two functions so i'd actually like you
to think of some examples
of functions of x and y that are
inseparable that cannot be split
into this i'm thinking of things like x
plus y squared x plus y quantity squared
um
is is not separable in this way
i don't think you should double check
that i just made that up on the spot
okay so the first assumption this is a
huge assumption
is that we are going to assume this uh
separation of variables
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to plug this into our partial
differential equation
and we're going to get ordinary
differential equations for f and for g
that have to be satisfied
so
let's do this so if i do del squared
of u and remember this is partial
squared u partial x squared plus partial
squared u partial y squared
okay so um
partial this and again we're gonna do
the chain rule so the second partial
derivative of this with respect to x is
just
f
x x
subscript here means partial derivative
i took two partials with respect to x
times g of y
now you could say plus
f of x g
x x of y but since g is a function of y
its partials with respect to x are zero
okay
okay so this is the first term of
laplace's equation the second derivative
in x
plus the second derivative in y is again
f of x
g
y y
of y
and of course this equals
zero okay we know that this equals zero
good so so this is laplace's equation if
we assume that we can split our function
u into a product of f x and g of y
and so now what we're going to do
is kind of play around with these a
little bit so i'm going to move one of
these over to the right hand side
because both of these add up to zero so
i can move one over to the right hand
side
and i can say so i'm going to rearrange
this and say f
x x
of x times g of y
equals minus f of x
g y y
y
and now i'm going to collect all of my f
terms on one side and all of my g terms
on the other everything that's a
function of x and everything that's a
function of y on different sides of the
equation
and i'm going to get
f
x x
divided by f these are both functions of
x
equals minus
g y y
over g
okay because these are
um
i collected all my g my y terms over
here and all of my x terms over here
good uh so
this if you think about it
only is a function of x so even though
these are partial derivatives with
respect to x f is only a function of x
so these are just normal derivatives and
these are normal derivatives uh with
respect to y
and one of the really cool things
about separation of variables is this
next step
is that these
two equations because they equal each
other these these two terms equal each
other
they both have to equal
constant lambda so i'm going to say this
is a constant
and if you have watched my videos before
you know that i love eigenvalues lambda
so i am calling this lambda because this
is going to be an eigenvalue you'll see
that in a few minutes
but these two terms have to be constant
and and i always pause and i ask my
students to think hard about why this is
so i'm going to pause for a minute and
you're going to think
i i got these equations by taking
this you know partial
uh differential equation equals zero so
i moved terms over i divided and
collected like terms you know my x terms
and my y terms
why do those have to equal a constant
and the answer
is because if this is only a function of
x
and if this is only a function of y
then for any y value
i i vary you know this equation it still
has to be equal to this one at every
single x value so because this is only a
function of x and this is only a
function of y the only way that those
can equal each other is if it's the
constant function if it's like you know
one equals 1 or 2 equals 2. you can't
have x equals minus y for all y and for
all x so the only way this is true for
all y and all x is that if they both
equal a constant
good
and so we're actually getting really
close to starting to solve this problem
so we've still set this up and i'm going
to take a big step back
or you can jump ahead to the summary or
you know i'm going to have these summary
moments where i summarize all of the
steps but i'm going to keep going just a
little bit
so what we've done so far
is we have assumed that we can split our
function into a product of f of x times
g of y we've plugged it into our partial
differential equation and now we have
recovered uh this relationship which i
claim
is two systems of ordinary differential
equations
so this in my mind is two systems of
ordinary differential equations we have
uh
f
x x
equals
lambda f
okay this is a ordinary differential
equation in f of x okay f is a function
of x so you really could think of this
as like f prime prime equals lambda f we
know how to solve this
and we have another differential
equation g
y y
equals minus
lambda g
and if you're a little quicker than i am
i've been thinking about this so i know
the answer but if you're a little
quicker
than i was you'll recognize that the
solutions of this are going to be things
like plus or minus you know e to the
plus or minus root lambda t or root
lambda x
and solutions of this are going to be
things like sines and cosines of root
lambda y's okay so these solutions of
these are going to be sines and cosines
solutions of these are going to be
exponentials good
and importantly these have our boundary
conditions here
translate into like initial conditions
for our ordinary differential equation
so at f
we're going to use our um
our x equals zero and x equals l
conditions here so f
of zero equals zero
and f of l
uh
f of l
has to equal f three
of y
okay this is a little messy i'm going to
i probably shouldn't have written that
down
but the x equals l
condition
is going to come from this one and
similarly we have these conditions on g
g ones are easier which is g at zero has
to equal g at h has to equal zero those
are these uh these conditions here okay
so now what we have is we've turned our
nasty partial differential equation
which is a function of x and y you know
two spatial variables
and we have by separation of variables
shown that now we can reduce this to two
systems of ordinary differential
equations and these ordinary
differential equations it's actually a
whole family it's infinitely many
ordinary differential equations for any
value lambda that i choose any value
lambda here this is absolutely true if
this is pi if this is negative 2 if this
is 15 this is still true
and so i get this whole family of
ordinary differential equations i solve
but i'll point out
that even though any constant lambda
makes this true
only special lambda remember eigenvalues
are special values only special
eigenvalues lambda will allow me to
satisfy these two sets of boundary
conditions uh
these kind of ode initial conditions so
that's that's really important
okay good um
and i'm just gonna think for a minute um
yeah realistically
this uh i'm gonna i'm gonna erase this
one we're going to come back to this
boundary condition so so i think at this
point you should you should be seeing
this looks like a much easier
system to solve because i have really
easy my boundary conditions give me
really easy kind of uh
can constraints on on my solutions here
whereas the f variables are going to be
nastier because this right hand
side
imposed temperature distribution so
that's going to be a little hairy so i'm
going to solve this g-y-y equation first
i'm going to find which special lambdas
allow me to satisfy these boundary
conditions and then once we have those
special lambdas we'll solve f and we'll
take all of our solutions and we'll plug
them back in to reconstruct u of x y
okay so that's what we're doing um
good i think we should just get into it
um we're already pretty far into it
so okay so now what i want to do
is i want to solve my gyy equation um
i might just do it down here because i
think i have enough space uh okay so
g-y-y
now we have a few different cases we
could do it if lambda is positive or if
lambda is negative okay so if lambda
let's say lambda is
um
greater than zero okay
i'll let you think about what happens
when lambda is equal to zero that's an
interesting case but but let's just
think about this for now so if lambda is
greater than zero
then essentially
this gyy equals minus lambda g the
solutions of this are sines and cosines
this is literally uh you know g prime
prime equals minus lambda g
and we know so you could uh you could
assume you know if gy equals e to the
alpha y
and you double differentiate it you'll
find that the eigenvalues of this have
to be
complex conjugate pairs plus or minus i
omegas
and so we know that we're going to have
solutions our sines and cosines
and so uh we're going to say
that our gys
are equal to um
um
because g zero equals zero i can't have
any cosine components so i could write
down you know sine of
root lambda y plus cosine of you know
root lambda
y but i can't have any cosine term
because of this boundary condition
because the cosine of zero is one it's
not zero so i'm only going to keep my
sine term so sine of
root lambda y
and now i have to find the really really
special
root lambdas that satisfy both of these
boundary conditions so we know that sine
of you know root lambda y
is zero
when root lambda is 0 or pi or
2 pi 3 pi 4 pi 5 pi so i'm going to
basically say
that if root lambda
equals some integer multiple of pi
and i'm pretty sure i needed this to be
okay so
when g of h when i plug in so lambda
root lambda h
has to equal an integer multiple of pi
when root lambda times h because i plug
in h here when that equals
an integer multiple of pi
then this uh satisfies that right
boundary
that top boundary condition so so that's
my condition is that root lambda equals
n
pi over h
essentially for all integers n for n
equals one two three four five six so on
okay so uh
for n equals one two three dot dot dot
dot
uh if n equals zero that's also fine you
can kind of work that out that if n
equals zero then this is just sine of
zero it's just a it's zero uh and so
that's also totally fine
so so now we have come to a important
kind of crux which is we know that this
equation was true for all lambda and so
these differential equations are also
true for all lambda
but there are only very special lambda
that satisfied these boundary conditions
the bottom and top boundary condition of
my pde
and specifically they're the they're the
uh the lambdas that satisfy this
equation so that sine of root lambda y
equals
zero when y is zero and when y is h
now it's easy every time y is zero this
is zero but when y equals h i need this
special relationship for lambda so
lambda has to satisfy this equation and
i'm going to get rid of my
uh my root here and i'm going to square
my other side so lambda equals
n pi over h quantity squared so if
lambda equals that for any value of n
that's an integer
this is a valid lambda that satisfies
these boundary conditions
and so now what i have
is a countably infinite set of ordinary
differential equations
for f and for g
accountably infinite sets for every n i
get a lambda and i have a corresponding
ordinary differential equation that
satisfies my boundary conditions
and the solution are sines with that
fundamental frequency
of root lambda in the in the vertical
direction
good
so i'm going to write this out just very
very explicitly so i don't forget i'm
going to say
maybe
probably should have color coded this g
of y
equals sine
of
n
pi over h
y so all of the functions g
in this separation of variables that
satisfy the top and bottom boundary
conditions
all of them are of this form for an
integer value of n that's super cool so
we've solved half the problem check okay
this video is going to go along
we're halfway through we've solved half
of the problem okay so now we have uh we
know what these guys are the g of ys are
signs with uh these perfect kind of
harmonic so if you think about a guitar
string
these kind of harmonic
eigenvalues that satisfy these boundary
conditions actually very much like a
guitar where you pin this in two places
there's only certain signs and cosines
that can exist and satisfy those pin
boundary conditions that's another
application of separation of variables
i'll show you in uh in another lecture
soon one of my favorites actually
good um
i'll let you think about what happens so
we already talked about when lambda
equals zero that's the same as when n
equals zero that's a perfectly valid
boring solution where this is the zero
function so that's not interesting
and if lambda is less than zero that
this is a good homework problem if
lambda is less than zero
then this equation now will have
solutions e to the plus and minus square
root of lambda y
and there is no way of satisfying both
of these boundary conditions equaling
zero
uh with e to the you know lambda y and
you know root lambda y plus e to the
minus root lambda y there's no way with
just exponential functions i can satisfy
these two boundary conditions so lambda
has to be positive and it has to have uh
this very special set
of lambdas to be to be valid
okay so essentially the big step one was
that we um i'm going to draw this out
because i think this is actually really
important and i have a little cartoon i
draw in my class which is the the first
step after separation of variables and
getting this system of ordinary
differential equations was we solved the
one with easy boundary conditions always
make your life easy solve the easy
boundary conditions first the ones that
are zero okay so in the y direction in
this case
and what we did was we essentially said
that you know in the y direction
from
let's say 0 to h
the only solutions
that can satisfy
this differential equation with these
boundary conditions that it has to be
zero at these these conditions
are these very very special
sine waves that have you know the right
i'm not very good at drawing sine waves
but very very special sine waves that
have the right
frequency so that they exactly are
pinned to zero at the bottom and the top
of my domain so that's super cool okay
and now the next step the second step is
that we're going to use these lambdas
and we're going to solve our hard ode
in f okay so now we're going to solve
our od and f
and we're going to use the solutions of
those eventually we're going to use our
boundary conditions to uh
to get the coefficients of this this
function
okay good uh so that is what we're doing
now so we've just solved the the y's now
we're going to solve the f the f's and i
think this actually is not that bad
so where do i want to do this
maybe i'll just cheat and use my notes
okay so
we know that f x x equals
lambda which is n
pi
over h quantity squared
of f
good
and we know that the solutions of this
are going to be
f of x
these are positive numbers here and so
we know that the solution of f prime
prime equals a positive number f
is going to be some constant
a
e to the
n
pi over h
x
plus some other constant b
e to the n pi the minus n pi over h
x
and technically for every this is an
ordinary differential equation for every
integer n it's a whole separate
differential equation so these are
possibly different coefficients a1 a2 a3
a4 for each of those values of n so this
is actually not that bad i should have
boxed this solution here
that corresponded to this solution here
and this is the solution of my x
equation now that i know that my
eigenvalues have to be
root n pi uh or sorry have to be n pi
over h squared
and here's where we get to use our
our easy x boundary condition so our
easy x boundary condition is that f of 0
has to be 0.
so i can plug 0 into both
of these equations and e to the 0 is 1.
and so i get
f of 0 equals a n
plus b n
equals 0
which means
b n has to equal minus a n okay so
anytime i see a b n
i can just swap this out for a
minus a n
i hope you caught what i did i plugged
in x equals zero
that killed the exponentials that just
became ones and i got a n plus b n has
to equal zero
which means b n equals minus a n okay
and i'm getting a little out of space
here but essentially
the sum of e to the plus you know
alpha x
minus e to the minus alpha x is just a
hyperbolic sine function
and so this uh
f of x maybe i'll just write it down
here so my f of x
is equal to
a n
it's actually equal to 2
a n
hyperbolic sine
of n
pi over h
x good
so all of
my x solutions have to have this form
this is just a basic basic like trig
identity is that this
equals 2 a n cinch
of n pi
over h x you can just you know verify
this yourself it's pretty easy if you
like complex analysis this is like a
homework problem and complex and so now
we also have this term
good
uh okay so i'm just going to barrel
through i'm going to go all the way to
the end and write out the whole solution
and then we're going to recap what we
learned and we're also going to think
about like what happened if i had
different
boundary conditions maybe i'll talk
about that a little bit if i had
different boundary conditions here these
were fixed temperature i basically have
these uh sides let's say in an ice water
bath so that they're fixed to be
temperature zero same on the left side
and maybe i hit the right hand side with
a blow torch to you know give it some
some constant thermal uh profile
but you know so these are fixed
temperature u equals zero
what if the we had a no flux condition
what if we had an insulating boundary
condition the partial derivative of u
sub x equals zero or the partial
derivative of u sub y equals zero
i'll i'll talk you through this in a
little bit but essentially what would
happen is we would get slightly
different boundary conditions here maybe
we would get
you know g sub y of zero equals g sub y
of h equals zero
in which case i would get cosine
solutions being the only ones that can
satisfy that zero flux condition and
these would all become cosines
um
other things uh other other things you
could do
here i think if i had an insulating
boundary condition on the left then i
would probably get coshes here
hyperbolic cosines i don't quite
remember you should work through this
yourself okay
but so now what we have is that the
solution of this partial differential
equation uh in in u
is equal to
and remember this will have this is true
for every single integer n for n equals
0 1 2 3 4 and so on
and so because it's true for all of
those if i add up all of those solutions
that's the solution of u so for every
single lambda here
i get one of these solutions and if i
add them all up that's my global
solution to you
so this is equal to
the sum
from n equals
1 to infinity and the reason i'm not
doing n equals zero is because um
it's boring because sine of of uh
zero is always zero so you could do n
equals zero and write this out but the
first term would be zero
and we have i'm actually going to write
my f of x is first so i have my a sub n
times uh
[Music]
times what times
let's say i could do a of n cinch
or a of n sine
i'm just going to do my sine first uh
let me move my cinch first
i have n
pi
over h
this is in the x direction
sine
of
n
pi over h
in the y direction so it actually
doesn't look that terrible
i get cinches in the x direction and i
get signs in the y direction okay and
cinch is you know it's going to look
like a decaying exponential plus a
growing exponential so something kind of
you know almost catenary-ish
and these are harmonic to satisfy those
boundary conditions in y
and i've gotten rid of this 2 here
because i am lazy and because this is a
undetermined constant so i can just say
that
i am defining a to have that
factor of 2 in there
this is the solution so this is the
actual solution of laplace's equation
okay actual solution of laplace's
equation
using separation of variables
now separation of variables does not
always work there are problems that are
non-separable okay there are problems
where you can't separate
the solution into a product of functions
and x times a product of functions in y
uh plenty of examples of that
but when you so so what i would
recommend is if you think your problem
is separable you make this assumption
you go through the steps and if at some
point you box yourself into a corner
where you can't satisfy your boundary
conditions or your initial data or
whatever
then you might conclude the separation
of variables doesn't work but in this
case we didn't hit any walls through
this procedure and we actually were able
to derive this full solution
pde here
okay so i did not determine these
coefficients a n yet this is kind of a
pain in the butt
i will do this in a minute these a and
these undetermined coefficients a n
these are super important there is one
boundary condition i haven't used yet
and that is this one
so if you think about all of the steps
we've done up until now we've used the
bottom and top uh boundary conditions to
solve my my functions in y to get this
this you know these perfect eigenvalues
and these eigenfunctions in the y
direction
we have used the
left boundary condition
to
for our f equations to show that b has
to equal minus a which gave us cinches
that give us the form of this equation
but these coefficients a n
we haven't determined what these are yet
and the only information left to
determine these coefficients
are these uh this this kind of nasty
boundary condition on the right okay so
i'm going to do that in a minute
um but what i want to do right now
is i just want to do a big recap okay
because some of you might not want to
pay attention to this you know deriving
a and i think it's amazing because this
is going to basically use the fourier
transform if you think about it these
coefficients
these coefficients are going to be the
fourier transform coefficients of this
function f 3
in this basis
of sines so it's absolutely amazing
connection uh to fourier analysis
um so the the recap here for me is is
the most important part
um
we have
introduced one of the most powerful
methods of solving partial differential
equations which is separation of
variables
1690
bernoulli
and essentially it allows us to
transform our partial differential
equation you make this assumption you
plug it into your partial differential
equation and you get out two systems of
ordinary differential equations you get
a set of ordinary differential equations
in
x
and you get a system of ordinary
differential equations
in
y where are my y's in y
and we know how to solve ordinary
differential equations they're
relatively easy especially linear odes
that are second order all of our
solutions are going to be exponentials
or sines and cosines that's it okay
and so that's you know that's that's a
big step one is you know step zero is
assume you can split your variables
step one is plug it into your pde and
derive a system of odes out
the next step step two is pick the one
that has easy boundary conditions not
the one that has hard boundary
conditions the easy one
and find the special values of lambda
the special constants lambda
that uh allow you to satisfy those
boundary conditions
and for me this is one of the most
beautiful parts is that those special
lambdas are actually eigenvalues they
are honest to goodness eigenvalues of
this ordinary differential equation that
satisfy these boundary conditions so we
have eigenvalues lambda
which are these
you know n pi over h squared for integer
n
and the corresponding eigen function so
these are the eigen functions
corresponding to those eigenvalues
lambda i'm actually going to write down
lambda n okay these are all
uh these are my lambda
n's i have countably many eigenvalues
lambda that satisfy these boundary
conditions and corresponding i have
eigenfunctions okay so i used to have
eigenvalues and eigenvectors but now we
have eigenfunctions because the
solutions are functions we live in a
function space a hilbert space if you
want to learn more about that check out
my fourier analysis series we talk all
about you know fourier
transforms and these eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions
okay that was step two i'm losing track
here i think that was step two solve the
one with the easy boundary conditions
step three is now that we have
determined those special lambdas plug
those into our hard our differential
equation with hard boundary conditions
uh and one of the boundary conditions
was easy this one here so i use that to
figure out that bn has to equal minus a
n that tells me that i get cinches out
and i am almost done that's like three
steps with a zeroth step and we get this
solution here and the only thing we
haven't done
uh is solve for this a n and i'll just
remind you you know this is a homework
problem i hope you all do it maybe i'll
do a little follow-up video of some of
the other ways we can perturb the system
but this was for u equals zero and u
equals zero and u equals zero
it's very interesting to try out what
happens if the you know partial
derivative in y equals zero what if i
have insulating boundary conditions that
changes uh these to g
y
you know sub y of zero and h equals zero
and that would change this to being so
that only the cosine solutions can have
their first derivative be zero on these
and so i'll get cosine solutions here
same fundamental eigenvalues same
cinches here but my uh gys would now be
cosine functions if i had insulating top
and bottom if i put styrofoam on the top
and bottom of this so really cool things
once you know how this works you can
pretty much solve all of these problems
you could solve this on a circle on a
disk you could solve this on you know a
ring you could solve this on lots of
different geometries
if you know this kind of basic procedure
of you know split plug it in solve your
differential equations solve the easy
one first find your eigenvalues plug it
into the blue equation
last thing i'm going to do now
so this is kind of where the video ends
except we don't have these a n's so the
last thing i'm going to do is actually
derive
these ans
and we're going to use our boundary
condition which is and i hope i have
room this is kind of a mess
is that
you at my right boundary condition you
at x equals l of y
equals this
f
of y boundary condition i'm going to
drop the subscript 3 because i can't
bear to write down subscript 3 every
time i have a y here
and that equals this summation up here
so it equals my sum
uh from n i know everyone hates it when
it squeaks i'm sorry uh n equals zero to
one
um a n
goodness gracious uh a n
cinch
of and now all i'm going to do is
anytime i see an x i'm going to replace
it with an l it's that simple so i have
n pi over h times l
this is a number
that's actually easier plugging in x
equals l made this easier this is just a
number
times sine
of n pi over h y
okay good that this is just all i've
done is i've just
re-capitulated my solution and i've
plugged in x equals l and i've said all
of this stuff and my solution has to
equal my right boundary condition at x
equals l it's that simple
and now this is where the fourier
analysis comes in and it drives me crazy
that you know when i was going to school
fourier analysis was its own semester
class and everyone thought it would be
really cool to learn fourier analysis
because it sounded you know neat
fourier analysis and isolation is boring
fourier analysis is a tool to solve
partial differential equations and
physics equations and i think it's a
crime to you know separate it and
quarantine it off from uh from
differential equations but
the way we're going to figure out these
a n's is what we're now going to do
is we are going to uh i'm just going to
write this out so i'm going to write out
the essentially the inner product of
this function y so the inner product and
and if you don't remember what an inner
product is in a hilbert space a function
space i'll put a link to the video in my
fourier analysis series where i talk all
about this it's actually really easy
it's the integral from 0
to h
of
f of y
times my sine
n
goodness gracious n or m i'm going to
use another variable m
h n pi over h
y
d y
this is literally just breaking f of y
into fourier coefficients okay this is
this is like the projection of f onto
the mth fourier coefficient so this is
the mph fourier coefficient of this of
this data f fy i think if this is data
because this is just a function that
someone gives me someone specifies and i
get to use it and so i'm going to
compute its fourier transform and get
its fourier transform coefficients
but now i'm going to plug in all of this
nonsense into that f of y and i'm going
to get something nasty but things are
going to cancel out
okay so this equals integral trying to
make this not squeak 0 to h
of my
god awful sum
of a and
cinch
which is just a number sinch
n pi l over h just a number
times this sign sine
n pi over h y
times this sine sine
m
pi over h y d y
now uh literally i just took this is the
fourier transform of f y this is one of
the terms of the fourier transform of f
y and i plugged in this expression of f
y my solution
and what you'll notice now
you know these are just numbers these
are numbers
and this inner product
can only this this this integral from 0
to h this is something you'll learn in
fourier analysis i call this an inner
product between these two functions
these are orthogonal functions if n is
not equal to m for any non-integer n and
m
for for any integer n and m that don't
equal each other this integral is zero
so this is only non-zero when n equals m
which means we can drop this uh
we can drop this summation here and this
n has to equal m
okay
and this n has to equal m and all of
these n's have to equal m's and i can
probably just make my ends m's without
erasing them
and so essentially what we get
is that this equals
a
m
this integral from 0 to h will have
a length scale h again this is just
details over two this is just from this
integral i'm just showing you what the
integral is
uh so so the integral forget all this
junk this is a constant this pops out
the integral of these two things when n
equals m is just one half times h it's h
over two so i get h over 2 am
sinch
m pi l over h
good
and so this is what this integral equals
okay
which means i can solve for am so now am
and i'll just call it a
m
equals
this thing here
equals
2
over
h
sinch
m pi l over h
moved all this over here times the
integral from 0 to h of f of y
sine
m pi over h y
d y this here
and let's just confirm
this here is this coefficient
so
this is a number number number
uh this is a function of specified
numbers and this is data this is my
boundary condition f of y so i can
determine these a coefficients
purely from taking the fourier transform
so it's essentially just some constant
times the fourier transform coefficients
of my data on my right boundary
condition so that that's how you get
these a n which i think is kind of cool
i know this made the video about 10
minutes extra long and some of you have
fallen asleep so you're welcome if it's
late at night
but i think it's really really important
to show that you actually get these
directly from you know this this fourier
transform this thing literally is
uh you know the nth
fourier coefficient of f of y of my data
on my boundary condition so that's
really cool
okay this is one of my absolute favorite
lectures because it tells you how to
actually solve pdes we haven't been
playing around we haven't just been
writing down conservation laws we
actually wrote down the
honest-to-goodness solution you could
plot this in python you could plot this
in matlab and you would actually get the
solution of laplace's equation for
for that you know this set of boundary
conditions
all right thank you